[Musique]
la vie si tous qu'on est astucieux paix
le plus sérieux à jouer et c'est devenu
un ami
je virevolte et je tourne et j'ai mal
comme tout fabrice et ce qui se passe je
me suis luxé une aile à ça c'est moche
j'ai été poussé par un chien et j'ai
raté mon envol alors est en fait assez
celle là
bah oui c'est dommage mais il faut quand
même travailler oui je sais bien bonjour
bonsoir bonsoir bonjour enfin tout ce
que tu veux tu peux leur dire ce but du
voyage la géographie oui allez l'affairé
fait john dit ça me ferait plaisir dima
bon ben je prends ma valise je viens
avec toi si tu veux je te suis où tu
veux moi non c'est moi je prends ma
valise et julien alors tu prends ma
valise et tu viens avec moi ils ne
commencent à faire alors je décolle là
c'est la carte politique du pays c'est
une carte géographique et politique
géopolitique qui dura se dit comme ça si
tu veux ça se dit comme ça alors regarde
lorsque j'ai mal à l'aise mal à l'aise à
ne remue pas trop alors voilà le pays
voilà le présent route la capitale est
en haut à droite on dirait un oeil oui
voilà très jolie jeudi être président
oui bon et toi là tu ne sais pas moi si
je sais tu dévoiles tout de suite le
drapeau je dévoile le drapeau bon tu
remarqueras que la capitale est tout
près de ses frontières
oui oui et oui plus pratique alors moi
je les trouvais bari 1 les abris si
j'avais pas mal à l'aise comme ils
savent ce qui me plairait oui c'est
sympa peau du pays oui voilà c'est rouge
blanc rouge rouge blanc rouge
alors nous allons maintenant passer à la
langue du pays la langue pour dire
bonjour ou digg ou guten morgen gouttes
m'aura bien union confederation à
l'accent ou par queen moyens ou non du
mouvement
oui voilà pourra trouver moi j'ai trouvé
ces traits qui remanie comme consonance
c'est tout à fait germanique
en fait il s'agit non pas de l'allemagne
mais de l'autriche pris au sto reich
alors là nous avons la capitale qui est
vienne vienne très près de ses
frontières via une qui pourra je vois
que la forme est bonne bon je vais dans
le jardin vador je vais tout de suite ne
déclenche pas alors s'assurer que avery
bien entendu bord alors à rodrigues qui
assaillent
eluchans d'amidon et attendons en parle
comme un humain comme c'est un moment
difficile
oui oui pas tourner ou non c'est pas ça
glisse alors on l'appelle fabrice et si
tu prends le web voilà voilà voilà
et voilà en pratique pouvait bien voilà
tu seras gentil de faire graisser la
porte parce que l les gonds ce coin que
nous allons jouer au point commun voilà
alors je rappelle comment les choses se
passent tout cas encore belbel époux
smoothie représentant chacun quelque
chose puis on entre eux un point commun
à nous de trouver lequel réquista
version voilà alors jeu comme un free
commence
bon et bien et figure toi que moi je
suis dans une grande maison
oui et puis j'ai beaucoup de dépendance
tu vois on peut mettre une salle à
manger à ma place on peut mettre une
un salon de lecture on peut mettre des
tas de choses tu vois on peut même me
partager en deux mots cloisonné avant je
suis oui et je peux être à tous les
étages peut être premier au
rez-de-chaussée dans l'écho
je peux être partout tu vois alors voilà
ce que je suis mairie je sers beaucoup
parce qu'on peut même fermé à clé si on
veut être tranquille tu vois pas en
touriste il veut mais moi c'est tout
théâtre qu'on me trouve d'ailleurs quand
vous venez au théâtre chers amis si pour
moi que vous veniez ah bon vous avez
raison j'ai tous les pouvoirs gp vous
faire rire ou vous faire pleurer vous
faire peur parfois j'ai besoin de
beaucoup de monde pour exister mais je
peux aussi me contenter de deux ou trois
personnes
j'ai une existence plus ou moins longue
si je vous plaît je vis très longtemps
mais si vous ne m'aimez pas je n'insiste
pas et je disparais au bout de 48 heures
et vous n'attendez plus jamais parler de
moi ah bon oui bon d'accord c'est comme
ça et pousse moussu à avoir au moins moi
je vais vous dire
vous me voyez très souvent et partout
oui mais il ya un endroit où j'aime
particulièrement me cacher pour être à
l'abri à ces dans une tirelire
quand je suis là je peux espérer qu'on
va me laisser tranquille pendant
quelques temps sens alors je cours sans
arrêt je vais demain on me met dans des
appareils compliqués on est en temps on
compte harry et puis on met change
contre des tas de choses du chocolat du
chewing gum des des tickets ah oui alors
il faut que je sois résistantes pour
supporter tout ça j'aime autant vous le
dire
et dire que ça fait des centaines
d'années que je mène cette existence
vous rendez compte
oh bah je crois que cette fois ci ça
n'était pas trop difficile vous avez
certainement trouvé d'accord avec moto
cancan oui oui oui
faisable en fait tu m'as parlé
certainement d'une une pièce d'un
appartement ou d'une maison grasset
c'est ça c'était ma pensée et voilà bel
bel devait être une pièce de théâtre
sans limite exacte maintien et enfin
pouces moussu une pièce de monnaie
oui oui oui tu as trouvé alors qui est
encore une fois le meilleur et on lui de
le dire j'ai honte de le dire mais c'est
toi tout de même sur connect belle belle
oui tu as bien quelque chose à faire je
crois maintenant oui mais en fait
j'étais en train de te regardes et tu
pourrais bien me laisser un petit peu de
contempler dans un temps sont toujours
le châssis chéri bien sur ma faim il
faut aller faire le jeu musical que les
messieurs mais tout est prêt dans une
instance je serai là bas et puis tu
viendras me rejoindre
nous sommes battus à la baisse et que
c'était fichu parti est lui très mal à
l'aise sur cette barrique
enfin qu'est ce qui laisse tout terminé
parce que c'est au tour de pouce moussu
et tu sais que pousse le sua avec
l'orthographe bien débat will roll
essayer de faire quelques petits progrès
peut-être aujourd'hui oui oui oui ça
j'espère et je crois que je vais
t'étonner aller jb oui alors que j'ai
souvent étonnés oui oui c'est alors tu
vas droit dans le bon sens allons bon tu
as ton marqueur ça y est ah oui c'est un
mot de combien de lettres et bien un mot
de 9 les trains roulants rapidement
c'est pas ça commence par un p o de
flêtre neuf lettres alors fait trois
quatre cinq six sept voilà et enfin la
dernière lettre 1 n
voilà très bien ah oui très bien alors
ben on y va c'est écoutent oui c'est
sûrement une fleur ça non non non non
c'est pas une fleur c'est sûrement un
arbre non c'est pas énorme non plus à
fruits et non j'ai pas à légumes non
alors c'est un animal on va bien sûr et
ben voilà c'est un petit animal 1 1
oui enfin ils aient les moyens quand
même ils y croyaient
oui les poids énorme enfin nantes and
animals antibes on est ce que c'est un
animal que nous connaissons en europe
bah non pas spécialement non non non moi
spécialement non non non on n'a pas en
france on ou non alors dans les eaux
peut-être à dans les eaux tu dit un
poisson alors annoncé pas c'est pas un
poisson
c'est infernal qui vit dans le froid
doivent te donne quand même des
invitations à au froid au froid ray est
ce que tu veux c'est pas en une lettre
oui péri le lhc un petit peu embarrassé
là alors je vais te donner la cinquième
lettres ou alors la cinquième la 5e les
difficiles ça alors alors la cinquième
c'est un jouet voilà l'un d'eux en 3 4 5
kg un jouet un animal qui vit au froid
alors attends je suis dit combien de
lettres
je sens que tu vas lui mais dix neuf
l'aide ne reflètent oui bah écoute moi
j'ai bien un animal qui irait là mais
jaeggy lettre à
c'est pas le pingouin par hasard si tu
as trouvé un seul pas moins c'est le
pingouin avec nos fenêtres
et oui alors écoutons parce que ça va
certainement être intéressant alors tu
les cris comment eh ben je l'écris pain
oui à qui n avait et comme lui peint
comme du pain du pas comme des pingouins
oui c'est ça hein ben oui tu es sûr que
paroisse ne s'écrit pas comme ça par
hasard pays n g o ui et non non non tu
l'écris comme ça oui tu fais pas de
faute alors évidemment oui oui c'est
peut-être plus tôt ça tu sais c'est moi
qui ai fait une faute a accusé le mes
enfants mais pas très bien ce qui fait
alors part gouin png auj
bah oui c'est beau comme du pain ce que
c'est encore trop
et moi dis moi tu abri tu sais que pour
les pingouins ya beaucoup de gens qui se
trompent pas ils savent peut-être
comment ça s'écrit mai
l'oeil à une chose et il les confondent
avec les manchots et c'est pas la même
chose non d'abord ils vivent
du côté du pôle sud alors que les
pingouins on les trouvera au pôle nord
et puis les manchots ne veulent pas du
tout tandis que les pingouins
il y à rim a tu vois je vois que je sais
quand même là c'est vrai ça c'est vrai
tu connais bien les amis m'ont à oui oui
oui il a raison d'ailleurs
et toi tout con con tu ne te fatigue je
regarde à droite je m'intéresse à tout
mais j'écoute amateurs vont quand même
pas mais ils mettent beaucoup quand même
howard on va retrouver bell bell ah oui
il fallait retrouver mail belle c'est le
jeu musical des vilains avec moi c'est
facile la musique du g 7 stade aurait
donné seulement 5,7
bliss oui il me semble que tu m'as
chasse italienne ont produit cette
brutale je ne suis pas brutal tu sais
bien alors tantôt car je suis fragile
oui oui je serai très gentil je le ferai
plus je te promène alors je vais te
raconter ma petite histoire je m'habitue
et tu complète par une note de musique
les mots que je ne termine pas au hockey
c'est une histoire de flers que je vais
te raconter et une fleur très connu
non ce n'est pas un sou à sou c'est ce
n'est pas un souci mais je crois que
pour découvrir le nom de cette fleur il
y a un très bon système system six
thèmes c'était oui et ce système c'est
d'attendre la suite des moniteurs ne
t'inquiète pas je ne vais pas te prennes
est entraîné dans un schéma compliqué et
c'est une espèce de pirates
or voient alors là c'est un lent
exactement 1 millirad c'est ça et je
suis sûr que si tu m'écoutes bien tu vas
trouver la solution la solution la
solution est facile avoue va pour
l'instant
alors dans cette histoire il ya une
jeune fille qui va faire un tour dans
son jardin et tu entends des voix comme
jeune da alors elle est béret sidéré
décidé récemment
s'il est bien une veillée réveiller
réveiller enfin elle ne s'appelle pas il
prend une grande inspiration tu veux
encore arrête encore respiration voilà
il tend l'oreille
et elle s'aperçoit qu'on lui parle
longtemps en français mais oh oh oh bah
oui là tu as la cavale et maintenant
pour deviner de quelle fleur il s'agit
l'iman les notes si c'est la seule
sirella ces kiss et chante à bages ce
temps à temps choisi
[Musique]
au volet jamais non
jamais
gentil coquelicot thi lac est bien
gentil coquelicot mesdames etc
et bien voilà c'est très mignon
parfaitement bravo un rebond c'est je
crois que j'étais un peu aidée je ne
suis pas trop dur avec toi mais j'en
fait une gratte
non c'est bon pour les démons grand
plaisir chaque mois le générique pour me
faire plaisir tu aimais bien me faire un
bisou j'arrive déjà pas d'amis qui se
plaint que la vie s'est désisté shops et
des choses mais comme je n'ai pas de
mine war n'est bon qu'à faire attention
les quatre parties les cas ça me sens
heureux car il aime aller
l'astuce ap
moore
[Musique]
pas joué depuis et c'est vouloir devenir
amis
[Musique]